[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in ein london war mal der
mittelpunkt eines weltreichs und heute
abend fühlt es sich wieder so an aus
aller welt kommen kaiser und königinnen
präsidenten und premier ministerin
sie kommen um einem staatsoberhaupt
einer regentin einem vorbild einer
freundin die letzte ehre zu erweisen es
kommen auch die die unter britischen
kolonialismus zu leiden hatten und sich
in zukunft gerne als republik sehen
würden
einfacher ist all jene staaten
aufzuzählen die nicht eingeladen sind
russland syrien afghanistan venezuela
belarus und myanmar allein daran ist zu
sehen dass wird morgen die wohl größte
diplomatische trauerfeier aller zeiten
und die staatsgäste treffen in london
auf eine ganz besondere stimmung wie
yasin herlein zeigt
sie ist schon auch ein bisschen schräg
die atmosphäre in london in diesen tagen
hinter diesen retro bikern mit den
linien 6 ist die schlange die schlange
aller schlangen die um den sagt der
queen zu sehen sie ist in aller munde
weil sie so lang ist so diszipliniert
und so geduldig aber warum nun wirklich
so viele menschen in iran stehen wollen
fragt man sich dann doch mit wir wollen
der queen die letzte ehre erweisen weil
sie so lange auf dem thron war allein
ist es vielleicht doch nicht getan der
zufall will es dass die schlange an der
kogit erinnerungs mauer vorbei führt die
mit den herzen für die vielen corona
toten die das land zu verschmerzen hat
die meisten in europa
dieses ehepaar aus wales hat elternteile
in der korona krise verloren und nun mit
dem tod der queen kommt er auf einmal
vieles zusammen
als wir hierher kamen um der queen
unseren respekt zu zollen und wir diese
mauer gesehen haben ist uns richtig
bewusst geworden wie tief unsere trauer
ist und sie hat uns dabei geholfen
so wie ihm geht es vielen die hier
vorbeikommen
ich habe meinen vater im juni 2020
ancona verloren es sind zwei harte jahre
gewesen aber jetzt kommen alle zusammen
in nationaler trauer und nationalem
stolz denn wie das alles organisiert ist
das ist großartig
tatsächlich ist an alles gedacht bis hin
zu decken für die wartenden wenn es kalt
wird in der nacht und dazu kommt noch
spontane privat initiative
schokolade herz erwärmt
nach dem parlamentsgebäude dort wo die
queen bis morgen früh noch aufgebaut ist
haben viele buchstäblich ihre zelte
aufgeschlagen um morgen einen ganz neuen
blick auf den trauerzug erhaschen zu
können einige die ganz unentwegten sind
schon seit donnerstag da geradezu
überwältigt von dem ereignis
es ist unglaublich es gibt keine worte
dafür dieses auf und ab der gefühle
ich habe mir auch die blumen angeschaut
die überall hingelegt werden die bilder
von kindern und grüße aus aller welt es
ist einfach umwerfend und perfekt an all
dem hier teilhaben zu dürfen
getrauert und respekt gezollt werden
kann inzwischen fast überall im zentrum
londons wie hier in some cases park auf
halbem wege zwischen parlament und
buckingham palast mit kinderbildern und
blumen eben und jeder mit seiner eigenen
geschichte
ich dachte es wäre schön dies mit meiner
tochter zu tun den tod der königin zu
markieren und dabei auch meiner beiden
großmütter zu gedenken
deshalb haben wir je eine rose für die
queen niedergelegt
das ist es womöglich was hier in london
in diesen tagen geschieht es geht um
kollektives trauern nicht nur um die
eine großmutter
es ist auch ein tag um an die
verbindungen zu denken zwischen
großbritannien und deutschland die
großen die kleinen die weltbewegenden
und die familiären der schrecken zweier
weltkriege und die ausgestreckte hand
zur versöhnung königin elizabeths
staatsbesuch 1965 11 ganze tage lang
bedeutete für die junge bundesrepublik
internationale reputation
sie war seitdem mehrfach hier denn jede
reise nach deutschland ist für die
britischen royals immer auch ein besuch
bei der verwandtschaft peter kunz
sie sprach recht gut deutsch die queen
sie hat es nun nicht allen auf die nase
gebunden bei einem der fünf
staatsbesuche in deutschland ließ sie es
anklingen
elisabeth oma queen mary war
deutschstämmig und natürlich der
prinzgemahl philip royal war man
deutschland zugewandter und verwandter
als man es in der britischen
öffentlichkeit gewöhnlich zeigen durfte
das bild vom hässlichen deutschen der
zwei weltkriege vom zaun brach bestimmte
auch als karikatur lange die wahrnehmung
dass
die queen half das zu ändern ihre visite
in deutschland 1965 war eine
versöhnungsgeste
der längste staatsbesuch ihrer amtszeit
außerhalb des britischen commonwealth
es war mit wenigen ausnahmen fröhlicher
herzlichkeit die immer wieder ermuntert
wurde durch jenes gewinnende lächeln
zweimal leerten die briten den deutschen
die grundzüge der demokratie in der
besatzungszeit nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg aber auch 1714 als ein
deutscher in protestantischer adels
folge den englischen thron besteigen
durfte georg der erste aus hannover war
absolutismus gewohnt musste in london
aber mit einem parlament zurechtkommen
das haus hannover regierte britannien
bis 1901 bis zu queen victorias tot auf
dem familienfoto links victorias enkel
der deutsche kaiser wilhelm der zweite
und in london jeden tag zu sehen die
goldene erinnerung an den vorzeige
deutschen prinz albert von sachsen
coburg und gotha
victorias verehrten ehemann
großbritannien die weltausstellung
geschenkten gewisser weise zwar sein
konzept die weltausstellung hat zum
ersten mal großbritannien natürlich auch
gezeigt als große technik nation als
große kulturnation der deutsche robert
prägte auch englands royale kultur er
kaufte schloss balmoral weil die gegend
ihn so sehr an seine fränkische heimat
erinnerte elisabeth die zweite lebte die
liebe zu diesem ort weiter
iraner olmert war es auch der den ball
mordtat an den eigenen kind entwarf die
königliche familie im schottenrock eine
der bleibenden deutschen ideen am
englischen hof
deutschland wird auf der trauerfeier für
die queen vertreten durch unser
staatsoberhaupt bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier jetzt hier im
heute-journal direkt aus der residenz
des deutschen botschafters in london
herr bundespräsident guten abend und
vielen dank dass sie bei uns sind
grün abend übernahmen nach deutschland
welche botschaft bringen sie denn mit
für die trauernden menschen im
vereinigten königreich
ja ich glaube viele waren in deutschland
etwas erstaunt welche betroffenheit
welche trauer der tod der queen in ganz
europa und darüber hinaus ausgelöst hat
ich kann ihnen hier mit blick auf das
was wir hier in london erlebt haben es
ist eine ehrliche und große trauer und
betroffenheit die menschen hier in
london zeigen und der tod der queen
glaube ich hat uns ja auch in
deutschland berührt und wenn man sich
fragt warum gibt es glaube ich nicht nur
einen grund es ist diese
besondere frau die ein jahrhundert
geprägt hat das staatsbegräbnis ist
deshalb ein jahrhundertereignis 70 jahre
regierungszeit das wird es
möglicherweise auch nicht mehr geben man
mehr isst das selbst erst
bewusstgeworden muss ich ihnen sagen als
ich zum antrittsbesuch hier in london
war 2017 und mir klar wurde die queen
hat den ersten bundespräsidenten
empfangen herrn hoyzer und sie empfängt
auch den zwölften in meiner ersten
amtsperiode vor fünf jahren in sofern
das ist eine ungeheure lange zeit in der
dann natürlich auch autorität
gewachsenes autorität durch ihre
beständigkeit durch ihre erfahrung durch
ihre pflichterfüllung und man muss sich
das glaube ich so vorstellen auch in
großbritannien ist man ja durch krisen
gegangen corona exit der krieg und die
folgen die das auch in der englischen
wirtschaft hat und man war es über 70
jahre gewohnt sich hinter dieser königin
zu versammeln und jetzt in ihren alle da
fehlt etwas und das fehlt eben nicht nur
in großbritannien und in london sondern
es fehlt weltweit weil sie als jemand
bekannt war der dann wenn sie das wort
ergriffen hat sich für möglichst
freundschaftliche beziehungen zwischen
staaten ausgesprochen und engagiert hat
und insofern fehlt eben nicht nur
großbritannien diese königin sie haben
es angesprochen diese trauerbekundungen
die man in london sieht die menschen die
24 stunden lang anstehen um ihrer queen
die letzte ehre zu erweisen da hat die
königin ja offenbar etwas an
zusammenhalt und gemeinschaftsgefühl
geschaffen was wirklich außergewöhnlich
ist was kann sich denn ein
staatsoberhaupt von dieser erfahrung für
sich selbst mitnehmen
ich glaube das was wir gesehen haben ist
etwas was man nicht nachahmen kann 70
jahre regentschaft
sowas wird kaum irgendwo auf der welt
mehr möglich sein und ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob wir das als republiken zu denen
der gehören wünschen sollte dass jemand
über so lange zeiträume im amt es
insofern kann man nicht nachahmen aber
ich glaube es zeigt sich dass die
königin mittel und wege gefunden hat
über die tagesaktuellen
auseinandersetzungen auch zwischen den
parteien in die bevölkerung hinein zu
wirken versicherung zu geben dass dieses
land trotz aller probleme eine zukunft
hat und das denke ich ist auch eine
aufgabe eines deutschen
bundespräsidenten jetzt wird diese
trauerfeierlichkeiten die sind ja jetzt
auch schon anders als übliche
staatsbesuche oder gipfeltreffen auch
anders als sie es gewohnt sind herr
bundespräsident sie mussten heute
warteschleifen über london drehen sie
sind zu diesem gespräch zu fuß gekommen
um dem verkehrschaos zu entgehen gibt
denn gerade dieses chaos jetzt auch die
chance zu gesprächen die sonst
vielleicht überhaupt nicht möglich wären
es gab viel möglichkeit zu gesprächen
aber vielleicht vorweg 1 ich nehme das
überhaupt nicht übel dass man hier auf
die idee gekommen ist die staatsgäste in
bussen zum buckingham palast zu bringen
235 delegationen die mit dem flugzeug
ankamen und die durch den londoner
stadtverkehr geführt werden mussten die
allesamt das bedürfnis hatten dem neuen
könig ihr beileid
mitzuteilen dass es eine riesen
organisations aufgabe und die haben die
briten in hervorragender art und weise
gelöst gleichwohl wir hatten mindestens
zwei zweieinhalb stunden die möglichkeit
mit anderen
staatsgästen zu reden mit dem
präsidenten von ghana und der
präsidentin vikki open habe ich ebenso
geredet wie mit dem französischen dem
slowenischen präsidenten der
moldawischen präsidenten und den
skandinaviern die heute hören also es
gab viele möglichkeiten miteinander ins
gespräch zu kommen und ich glaube diese
möglichkeiten haben auch alle genutzt
weil wir zwei jahre hinter uns haben in
denen solche begegnungen kaum möglich
waren jetzt ist ja die welt aktuell in
einer wirklich schwierigen verfassung in
einer schwierigen lage ganz viel
vielerlei hinsicht was kann denn so eine
trauer versammlung der welt zeigen gibt
es da etwas was sie sich auch ganz
persönlich vornehmen
ich glaube wir sollten das nicht
unterschätzen dass menschen die
verantwortung tragen miteinander ins
gespräch kommen das ist viel wert aber
wir dürfen glaube ich nicht erwarten
dass von solchen begegnungen am rande
von begräbnissen und trauerfeier neue
initiativen etwa für
friedenslösungen ausgehen oder hier
plötzlich ideen wachsen wie der krieg in
der ukraine zu beenden ist aber dass
menschen miteinander ins gespräch kommen
dass man nach einer solchen trauerfeier
wieder zum telefonhörer greifen kann
sich ziehen kann auf diese gespräche die
hier stattgefunden haben das für sich
genommen ist gut und hoffentlich eben
auch die erfahrung von vielen dass das
sprechen miteinander das treffen
nützlich ist und dass wir auch abseits
solcher ergebnisse fortsetzen solche
erlebnisse fortsetzen bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier im heute-journal
herr bundespräsident vielen dank für das
gespräch
ich danke ihnen danke
wir haben es in dem gespräch dass wir
aus termingründen vor einer halben
stunde aufgezeichnet haben ja schon
gehört so viele staatsgäste was der
aktuell in london geschieht ist auch
eine herausforderung für die logistik
für die sicherheit luckwald bord hat
mehr dazu
für zwei tage der trauer wird london
wieder das zentrum der welt us präsident
biden ist gekommen um von der queen
abschied zu nehmen auch der kaiser von
japan david o der sonst nicht an
beisetzungen teilnimmt alter adel wie
spaniens ex könig juan carlos jüngere
präsidenten wie frankreichs makro
arabische potentaten wie scheich al
maktoum von dubai die einst die
ölförderung der briten in ihren emiraten
verstaatlichten und heute wohl reicher
sind als das frühere empire teil werden
sie einer grandiosen choreografie
ausdruck des britischen
selbstverständnisses
premierminister trio erinnerte daran
dass die queen auch staatsoberhaupt der
kanadier war
fast die hälfte der zeit in der es
kanada gibt war sie unsere königin ich
war sieben als sich ihre majestät zum
ersten mal traf sie war immer da in
meinem leben
constant von einem riesigen verlust
sprach präsident biden die queen
hinterlasse eine große lücke wir sind
mit dem herzen bei allen menschen im
vereinigten königreich sie können sich
glücklich schätzen wie wir alle diese
königin 70 jahre gehabt zu haben
beim empfang am abend kennt das
protokoll feine unterschiede die einen
kommen im bus darunter bundespräsident
steinmeier andere etwas feiner in der
gepanzerten luxuskarosse für die
sicherheitsbehörden ist das mega event
eine herausforderung 10.000 polizisten
sicherheitskräfte soldaten
scharfschützen sind im einsatz denn
neben der königlichen familie und all
den monarchen staats und regierungschefs
werden auch eine million besucher morgen
in london erwartet
montag wird der größte und wohl auch
komplexeste einsatz sein den wir je
hatten
unterdessen defilieren die menschen
weiter am sarg der monarchien vorbei am
nachmittag wurde die warteschlange
geschlossen bis morgen früh noch können
sie hier abschied nehmen von ihrer queen
vor knapp einer stunde dann 20 uhr
ortszeit hielt das land innen
für eine schweigeminute ein moment
stillen gedenkens auch am regierungssitz
in downing street 10 bevor morgen vor
den augen der welt eine königin zu grabe
getragen wird
das zdf überträgt den
trauerfeierlichkeiten für die queen
morgen ab 9 uhr im fernsehen und im netz
auf zdf heute
und jetzt weitere nachrichten die geduld
der eu kommission mit dem mitgliedsstaat
ungarn scheint jetzt ein ende zu haben
jedenfalls lassen die nachrichten aus
brüssel heute auf reichen hanna
christian ist es eine premiere für
brüssel die eu kommission will ungarn
zahlungen in höhe von 7,5 milliarden
euro aus dem eu haushalt streichen
hintergrund sind verstöße gegen
prinzipien der rechtsstaatlichkeit das
geld sei in ungarn nicht ausreichend vor
missbrauch geschützt erklärte eu
haushaltskommissar hahn budapest hatten
reformen angekündigt um die sanktionen
noch abzuwenden
ob das geld tatsächlich gekürzt wird
entscheiden letztendlich die
mitgliedstaaten mindestens 15 länder mit
mindestens 65 prozent der eu bevölkerung
müssen zustimmen
auch nach dem abzug der russischen armee
im nordosten der ukraine geht der
beschuss weiter in der befreiten region
haag wurden reg raketeneinschläge
gemeldet und der britische geheimdienst
warnt russland greift das vermehrt
zivile ziele an um die moral der
bevölkerung zu untergraben
ukrainische ermittler sichern in dem
gebiet weiter beweise für
kriegsverbrechen
einer der vorwürfe folter inzwischen
seien dort mehr als zehn folterkammern
entdeckt worden
mehrere bundesländer haben deutliche
kritik am geplanten dritten entlastungs
paket der bundesregierung geäußert dabei
geht es vor allem um die finanzierung
als keinesfalls
zustimmungsfähig bezeichnete bayerns
ministerpräsident söder das paket
gegenüber der welt am sonntag und darf
der bundesregierung mangelnde absprachen
vor das paket sei für die länder im
rahmen der schuldenbremse nicht zu
finanzieren niedersachsens
ministerpräsident weil forderte
angesichts der belastungen eine
aufhebung der schuldenbremse
bei den jüngsten kämpfen zwischen
tadschikistan und kirgisistan ist die
zahl der toten weiter gestiegen
auf dieselseite sind laut behörden 46
menschen getötet worden tadschikistan
meldet 35 tote die lage bleibt
angespannt
die zentralasiatischen staaten streiten
seit dem zerfall der sowjetunion über
den verlauf ihrer rund 1000 kilometer
langen grenze russlands präsident putin
forderte beide länder auf den konflikt
friedlich beizulegen
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht man
macht ja mittlerweile jeden brief des
energieversorgers mit bangem blick auf
was da kommt an abschlagszahlungen und
preiserhöhungen ist gewaltig auch die
energieversorger selbst bangen auch
solche die in der vergangenheit satte
gewinne machten rufen jetzt um hilfe und
die ministerpräsidenten warnen davor was
passiert wenn die rund 900 stadtwerke in
deutschland finanziell weiter ins
schlingern geraten mit bitteren folgen
für das öffentliche leben thomas bärsch
berichtet aus sachsen
noch im letzten jahr machte die
verbundnetz gas ag aus leipzig kurz vng
millionengewinne mit günstigem gas aus
russland gas das nun fehlt und dass die
vng zu aktuellen weltmarktpreisen
ersetzen muss will sie ihre kunden
weiter verlässlich beliefern kunden wie
die stadtwerke in leipzig dass die vng
nun staatshilfen beantragt stößt hier
auf großes verständnis aber wir
verstehen als kommunale unternehmen
nicht warum große verbundunternehmen
große importeure gerettet werden das
finden wir gut aber wir verstehen nicht
warum dieser schutz nicht auch für
kommunale energieversorger dienen
daseinsvorsorge gedanken folgend gelten
soll auch die stadtwerke sind in
bedrängnis denn schon bei den
preisanpassungen jetzt häufen sich
anrufe von verängstigten kunden die
stadtwerke sehen ein riesen problem auf
sich zukommen
die dramatischen preissteigerungen die
wir haben unsere kunden weitergeben
müssen führt am ende dazu dass ein teil
unserer kunden in das man vielleicht
nicht mehr bezahlen können oder nicht
alles bezahlen kann und es ist keine
lösung dann eine absperrung zu vermeiden
oder sogar zu verbieten sondern auch wir
müssen ja als unternehmen unsere
energien bezahlt bekommen weil wir
bezahlen sie selber im einkauf deswegen
wurde ein deutlicher ausfall von
kundenzahlungen unsere eigene existenz
auch gefährden mit dem ruf nach einem
schutzschirm finden die stadtwerke mit
leipzigs oberbürgermeister einen
prominenten mitstreiter für ein
schutzschirm nicht nur für sie sondern
für alle lokalen versorger wir sprechen
von 900 stadtwerke in deutschland und es
gibt gar keinen anderen weg als
staatliche hilfen zu organisieren egal
in welcher form ob beteiligung oder
kapitalanlage oder ein darlehen aber wir
brauchen die hilfe des staates ansonsten
geht's endlich näher und nicht nur für
die stadtwerke denn oft liefern die wie
hier im sächsischen wurzeln ihre wärme
nicht direkt an den endverbraucher
sondern an wohnungsunternehmen und wenn
dann deren mieter ihre rechnungen nicht
mehr begleichen können diese gefahr sehe
ich und ich sehe einen tag später die
gefahr dass uns die wohnungsunternehmen
dann auch bloß nicht mehr bezahlen
können wenn sie das geld von ihren
endkunden nicht mehr bekommen und dann
rutscht man alle beide oder alle drei
dann in so einer
liquiditätsengpass und da stelle ich mir
die frage wie dr oft haben die lokalen
versorgern langfristig kalkuliert dass
gast dass etwa die stadtwerke grimma
jetzt noch preiswert an ihre kunden
weitergeben konnten sie sich vor zwei
jahren billig vertraglich sicher doch
die stadtwerke müssen nun teuer
nachkaufen für sie endet die krise also
nicht wenn die preise wieder sinken im
gegenteil übernächsten jahr könnte es
dann eben sein dass uns kunden verlassen
durchaus zu recht wenn dann preise
fallen und wir aber über unsere
kalkulation noch teurere mengen im
portfolio haben die natürlich auch
weitergeben müssen auch für diese fälle
brauchte es einen schutzschirm für
stadtwerke damit auch sie diese krise
auf raten überstehen und damit ein
system nicht gänzlich zusammenbricht
so jetzt in der sendung der sonntags
sport mit hanna und da hatte heute die
deutsche basketball-nationalmannschaft
allen grund zu jubeln nach der bitteren
niederlage im halbfinale der em gab es
am abend die chance auf die
bronzemedaille für das deutsche team und
die hat es genutzt auf diesen moment
haben die deutschen basketballer 17
jahre warten müssen die erste
em-medaille seit 2005 dementsprechend
gefeiert die dbb-auswahl legt
konzentriert und routiniert los hält den
gegen aus polen lang auf abstand bester
spieler mal wieder dennis schröder der
soft insgesamt 26 punkte bringen nur im
letzten viertel ist noch mal zittern
angesagt die polen können den ausgleich
erzielen die deutschen riesen aber den
turbo ziehen wieder davon und lassen
sich den sieg nicht mehr nehmen 82 69
ich glaube wir haben deutsche basketball
wieder ein bisschen sexy gemacht
sexy auch die medaille man könnte fast
meinen bronze sei das neue gold
in der fußball bundesliga gab es heute
drei begegnungen union berlin besiegte
den vfl wolfsburg mit 2 zu 0 der vfl
bochum und der erste fc köln trennten
sich 1 zu 1 und beim dritten
sonntagsspiel trafen die tsg hoffenheim
und der sc freiburg aufeinander
endstand 0 zu 0
in der karibik hat hurrikan fiona puerto
rico erreicht auf der kompletten insel
mit ihren mehr als drei millionen
bewohnern ist der strom ausgefallen
mit theologen erwarten historische
regenmengen und warnten die bevölkerung
vor lebensbedrohlichen überschwemmungen
wo es präsident biden rief den notstand
für das us außengebiet aus
die klimakrise stellt uns alle die
gesamte welt vor enorme
herausforderungen wir müssen mit
überraschungen klarkommen mit bislang
unbekannten phänomenen und ja auch mit
katastrophen heute abend zeigen wir
ihnen was hitze und dürre in diesem jahr
auch zum vorschein gebracht haben es ist
eine längst vergangene welt die da
plötzlich mitten unter uns auftaucht
fundstücke schätze eine einmalige
gelegenheit für die wissenschaft und
auch ein wettlauf mit der zeit mariella
sonntag und christian kirsch nehmen uns
mit
heiße sommer lassen menschen leiden
pflanzen und tiere dem luftbild
archäologe dr song aus bochum
ermöglichen vertrocknete landschaften
allerdings auch völlig neue perspektiven
sei es 2018 haben wir diese extrem heiße
sommer das heißt meistens schon im
frühjahr werde das ist ja heiß und
trocken und dadurch wird der unterschied
im boden viel deutlicher wir sehen wie
die grundrisse wie durch gepasst das
heißt sie sehen dann im wunder die
spuren von bauwerke zum beispiel wurden
anlagen oder hausgrundrisse das können
sie alles im lot racing
tiefe gräben speichern mehr feuchtigkeit
und so fordert die dürre neues zutage
zugeschüttete flussläufe oder grundrisse
ehemaliger bogen
europa im dürre sommer 2022 wie hier am
deutschen reihen taucht vieles auf
spaziergänger finden schrott aller art
und immer wieder hinterlassenschaften
des zweiten weltkriegs waffen bomben
schiffe wie hier in der donau auch
historisches taucht auf
ein frühgeschichtlicher steinkreis in
einem halbleeren stausee in spanien
derzeit nicht unterwasser
archäologen warnen die trockenheit
gefährdet alles was da plötzlich im
trockenen liegt die meisten der funde
sind im erd- feuchten und das bedeutet
da sind sie auch gut konserviert und
sobald es denn trockener wird werden
diese kunden sehr stark angegriffen
könnt euch der kaputt gehen ganz
besonders bei organischen materialien
wie leder und holz und zur die sind
eigentlich wenn sie im wasser liegen
oder um von feuchtigkeit und geben sind
besser konserviert als im trockenen
die extreme dürre hat auch teile
nordamerikas erfasst lebt hier in texas
in einem vertrockneten flussbett spuren
von sauriern frei
lässt sonst überflutete bauten in
spanischen stauseen auferstehen hier die
ruinen eines historischen badehauses
der klimawandel gefährdet kulturgüter
durch schwankende wasserspiegel
ich habe das auch mit zwei
phänomen zu kämpfen einmal die große
hitze die bei binnengewässern und bei
bächen und so für aus trocken sorgt und
gleichzeitig die große hitze die zum
anstieg vom meeresspiegel führt und dann
eben in den küstennahen regionen alle
archäologischen denkmäler überschwemmt
zu wenig wasser oder zu viel der
klimawandel bringt geschichte ans licht
und jede menge müll darunter leiden alle
nicht nur die menschen
ihre bilder und jetzt wie immer sonntags
der blick in die kommende woche hier ist
der heute journal ausblick von kamran
safari
[Musik]
rund 150 staats und regierungschefs
werden ab dienstag zur un-generaldebatte
in new york erwartet hauptthemen werden
der ukraine krieg und die energiekrise
seien mit dabei auch russlands
außenminister lawrow und der ukrainische
präsident sei lenski per videoschaltung
bundeskanzler scholz wird vor ort seine
erste rede vor der generalversammlung
halten
ebenfalls am dienstag für der
europäische gerichtshof in luxemburg
sein urteil über die
vorratsdatenspeicherung in deutschland
verkünden sie ist politisch umstritten
und derzeit ausgesetzt ermittler sehen
sie aber als wichtiges mittel zur
aufklärung schwerer verbrechen
die förderung demokratischer bildung im
kindes und jugendalter
das zentrale thema des kinder- und
jugendbericht der bundesregierung
2020 von der alten bundesregierung
vorgestellt wird er am donnerstag im
bundestag diskutiert der bericht fordert
unter anderem kinderrechte im
grundgesetz
am sonntag werden die italiener eine
neue regierung wählen giorgia meloni von
der postfaschistischen fratelli d'italia
gilt als favoritin auf den
ministerpräsidentenposten die neuwahlen
sind nötig da mario draghi im juli
zurückgetreten war und
jetzt der blick auf die wetteraussichten
morgen im südwesten meist freundlich und
trocken sonst wechselnd bewölkt mit
vielen schauern und kurzen gewittern
bei lebhaften nordwestwind höchstwerte
zwischen 11 und 17 grad am dienstag
viele schauer ab mittwoch wieder mehr
sonne und auch wieder etwas wärmer
wie schön das war unsere welt an diesem
sonntag wir danken herzlich für ihr
interesse ab morgen freuen sich hier
marietta slomka und heinz wolf aus wir
wünschen ihnen jetzt einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]